bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france une nouvelle
expertise donc deux ans et demi après le
drame qui remettent en cause en gelée
dit la première quel regard vous portez
sur ce rapport
ce rapport est très accablant contre la
ville de paris et la responsabilité de
la ville de paris est forcément
toujours la mairie paris mis en cause
encore avec ce rapport
mais concrètement selon vous quelle
valeur cette expertise elle peut avoir
en finalement elle va pas vraiment
changé le cours de l'enquète et du
préfet contre la mairie de paris et le
syndicat ben non elle ne changera pas et
ne changera pas dans le sens où la
mairie de paris mise en examen
au niveau de l'expertisé enfin les
expertises au niveau du pénal
tout est clair je veux dire le syndic
est mis en examen
la mairie de paris aussi
là ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'au
niveau de l' expertise aux civils les
experts n'ont pas toutes les pièces
n'ont pas les pièces qui ont servi un
expertise au pénal puisque l expertise
de [ __ ] a démarré avant donc c'est le
syndic un qui est donc mise en cause au
niveau des indemnisations faisant des
tours
on est on en est toujours au même au
même point aujourd'hui nous sommes en
attente d'une réponse du conseil d'état
puisque la mairie de paris ne souhaite
pas indemniser les victimes sans cette
réponse
du coup et victimes sont toujours dans
la même situation au bout de presque 3
ans bientôt nous attend nous sommes à
deux ans et demi trois ans bientôt le 12
janvier 2022 et la situation ne fait que
[Musique]
s'aggraver en tous les cas pour les
victimes au niveau psychologique c'est
c'est dramatique
alors vous dites que la mairie de paris
refuse pour l'instant d'indemniser
comment vous expliquez ce blocage est ce
qu'elle peut faire autrement
oui elle peut faire autrement et nous
lui avons trouvé les associations et
plusieurs avocats qui était possible
d'indemniser les victimes sans engager
de sa responsabilité
sauf que elle s'est engagée le 28 28
janvier devant les une partie des
victimes s'est engagé d'indemniser avec
ou sans loi ça a été ces mots
et après après ça plus rien
si ce n'est d'un retour de ses avocats
qui acceptent ou
la mère de paris accepte d'indemniser
mais avec une loi
yann lui avons en effet un nous lui
avons trouvé un des avocats maître
maître de froment qui a
enfin on a un rapport complet
qui précise bien qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de mettre en place un accord
cadre avec une loi
mais la mairie de paris ferme les yeux
là dessus et
ils bloquent mais honnêtement pour les
victimes en tous les cas pour toutes les
victimes grièvement blessées
c'est une tactique
une façon de bloquer les victimes pour
on est au milieu d'un jeu politique
alors un jeu politique c'est à dire
la maire de paris
donne si on peut dire le bébé à l'état
qui doit répondre de savoir si elle peut
ou pas indemniser les victimes sans loi
et on n'a pas de réponse de la déléguée
interministérielle des deux victimes par
rapport à cette question
ce que vous nous expliquer c'est que ça
va au delà ce blocage ce n'est pas
seulement la mairie de paris qui est
mise en cause mais ça va beaucoup au
delà c'est à dire au niveau de l'état
c'est ça des autorités bah c'est surtout
la mairie de paris qui se sert de l'état
pour bloquer en fait la mairie de paris
est complètement est apte à
indemniser les victimes
je répète indemniser les victimes
ce n'est pas à un moment d'en faire
enfin elles ne vont pas sans réussir
avec une indemnisation
simplement elles vont pouvoir payer des
frais pouvoir subvenir subvenir à leurs
besoins
si ce n'est juste des réparations
aussi payer tout ce qui est suivi
psychologique etc qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas pris en charge et qui est très très
lourd c'est c'est une réaction il ya une
nouvelle médiation c'est le 8 décembre
prochain
qu'en attendez vous or il ya eu la
première médiation enfin la première
médiation la première
présentation jugée et cetera le 1er
septembre
il y en a de nouveau rendez vous le 8
décembre
la médiation doit se mettre en place ce
qu'il ya c'est que la mairie de paris
avec celle de se mette autour de la
table mais toujours dans l'attenté cette
réponse conseil du conseil d'état
c'est-à-dire sans cette réponse elle n'y
va pas
et on attend
merci beaucoup à vous linda sarwar pour
avoir répondu à nos questions et demande
pardon on demande toutes les victimes
demandent à la à la maire de paris
madame hidalgo de débloquer la situation
des victimes
ça fait deux ans et demi honnêtement
c'est c'est juste pas possible
juste un calvaire de laisser les
victimes dans ces situations des
victimes qui ont explosé dans le
neuvième en plein coeur de paris donc il
s'agit vraiment des victimes de la maire
de paris de ses victimes elle peut pas
nous elle peut pas les laisser comme ça
voilà votre message est passé donc un la
maire de paris anne hidalgo merci à vous
lille d'hazard war directrice à des
hôtels ibis styles et mercure de la rue
de trévise présidente de l'association
des victimes et de rescapé de
l'explosion de la rue de trévé